before that same day which was last
Wednesday I had to jump out of an uber
in the middle of an intersection yeah
what why I jumped into an uber with a
very rageful driver like he went into a
full [ __ ] rage and I had to jump out
of the car he um so he picked me up and
he seemed a little bit like he was
already in a bad mood and he couldn't
when i en't when you know when when you
when you enter the car the driver has to
hit start or passenger is in the car
right so that that way or pickup that
way you know they can charge you the
money right and I guess he didn't pay
his phone bill so right when I got into
the car he couldn't um charge me for the
ride and I realized what was happening
because his maps was his maps a Google
Maps wasn't working he didn't his uber
app wasn't working so I said hey you
know sir just like close down all your
apps and maybe start it up again and
maybe it'll work you know and it didn't
work so I struck a deal with him I was
like you know what I was like looks like
you're having a bad day I'll pay you the
fare was only supposed to be five
dollars it was only like three miles
away and I was like I'll give you 20
bucks I was like just get me to where I
need to be that's I thought that was
what I thought was the nice guys having
a bad day right what do you say midway
through the trip I I because I was using
the maps on my phone for directions I
was like let's just use my phone don't
worry about it
he starts pounding on his steering wheel
like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I know horns honking yeah like getting
angry and he's like where the [ __ ] I go
next he's like asking me for directions
I was like oh you're gonna make a left
on Highland and I was like sir I'm just
trying to help you like it you know and
and then I was like hey make a left here
but you might want to go stay on the
right lane trying to give him like
trying to give him like tips you know
and he raised his [ __ ] hand like this
I'm sitting in the back and he's like I
know how the [ __ ] Franklin works like he
tried to shush me in the middle of the
[ __ ] intersection I had ten dollars
because I knew that if I he was probably
not he seemed dangerous to me yeah if I
didn't pay him I knew he was a type
chase my ass down so the fair was only
supposed to be five bucks I threw him a
ten I know and I [ __ ] jumped out of
the car and I filed a complaint to uber
and they have not responded to me at all
but I screenshot at everything and I was
stuck in the middle of Hollywood because
I couldn't even get another uber because
his app had frozen so I couldn't like my
yeah I couldn't exit out of mine
how many start what was the star rating
for so you know something bad must have
happened because our ratings actually
not as well when I will run went to the
nor MacDonald thing that happened to me
- oh really
uber driver yeah I mean Norma Donald has
his shell right so it was in Venice and
they go we got a car so they picked me
up and halfway during the ride I don't
know what happened but the the the
ticket was lost or disconnected or hmm
yeah so then he just pulls over on
Venice Boulevard
it broke get out I go that's not how
yeah yeah but I don't even I didn't even
know was an uber mm-hmm
they did it they sent it for they sent
for me right I go yeah okay well I have
like 100 bucks in my pocket so just
drive me to the place and I'll pay you
know broke get out I go and then I'm
calling the guy right and then the
producer of the thing and they're like
oh my god and I'm sitting in a car now
with this guy on the side of Venice
Boulevard and we're not moving and I
have to tape this thing so we have to
get there but finally like you know
after about 15 minutes they call them
and something Nate you know they
arranged it but he was visibly angry and
so he drew the second half of it was
like a angry and angry driver in danger
racing so I think it
boobers got to fix that it's not it look
99.999% of all my uber rides are
perfectly uneventful it's just I would
the one thing I would appreciate is look
like I'm a chick right the guy was
obviously in some type of like
aggressive mode and the fact that I had
I felt so unsafe that I had to jump out
of the car is I deserve a response at
the very least what I'm saying is this
uber
right to their drivers that have that
kind of like when customers have that
kind of experience the consequences
should be very severe yeah not like okay
one strike
like no strikes no because it's like
because for me I'm not out oh poor guy
hmm I don't know much about it I've
taken them because I don't know I don't
trust it like I'd rather take a cab but
they're supposed to have what's the face
about George yeah all males are more
screened the drivers are screened yeah
first of all Kathir same background
which cab I know for a fact that I'm
gonna get to my destination I know it
for I have never been in the cab all the
thousands of cabs ever been know where
they pulled over and said get out yeah
this is just two stories between us two
that should never happen because as a
cake with a cab they're a part of a
company and they could get fired yeah
loser medallion yeah yeah no I want to
finish this with him so now are you
shaking your head [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like
it comes out in everything that he does
no and he can't get over this Jessica
thing she doesn't like you dude get over
positive energy
[Music]